this week on brian ross investigates
the apostles trial
the leader of the evangelical church
with millions of followers now set to go
on trial for rape and the sex
trafficking of young girls in his
congregation
and it still appears
to be efficient
motion
is denied
a judge in los angeles rejects his
lawyer's last-ditch effort to get the
charges thrown out they hid it and they
gave us a report in which they altered
it they edited it and they doctored it
after three years a day of reckoning is
now coming for the man who says he is
christ on earth
well i cried we we were shaken we hugged
we celebrated
plus a taste of freedom after 30 years
crossland green was released from prison
for a murder he says he did not commit
the one good thing i can tell you about
my feelings that there's no hatred
something happens and you know they say
a black guy did it and the black guy
gets convicted
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
editors of mediaite mr president you've
said many times that this election was
rigged that there was much fraud
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross and we
begin tonight with the apostles trial a
trial date has now been set for the
leader of an evangelical church accused
of 23 counts of rape and sex trafficking
involving underage girls in his own
congregation they san joaquin garcia
says he has more than 5 million
followers and claims to be christ on
earth the church has stood by its leader
even as the graphic details of his
alleged sex crimes have played out in
court
this week a judge in los angeles
rejected defense arguments to throw out
the charges and our rhonda schwartz was
in the courtroom as the judge set a
trial date for early june
that's right brian a hearing in a los
angeles courtroom this week has finally
brought to an end nearly three years of
legal wrangling and delays the man who's
known to millions of followers as the
apostle nacien joaquin garcia
is set to face trial in june
he faces more than 20 counts of child
sex abuse involving young members of his
own church
despite claims by the defense team that
prosecutors have falsified evidence
against their client an l.a county judge
has ruled the criminal trial will go
forward the prosecution cannot play hide
and go seek
the prosecution cannot
bury a piece of evidence
on a shelf in a warehouse
they hid it and they gave us a report in
which they altered it they edited it and
they doctored it this motion is
a last-ditch attempt to avoid a trial in
this case
they can't win on the real factual owner
and it still appears to be efficient
motion reconsider is denied
convicted the man known as the apostle
faces life in prison but his church
continues to stand behind him says he's
been unjustly accused and the charges
should be dismissed brian
thank you ronda and we're joined now by
social martin a former member of the
church and a survivor of abuse she says
began when she was a teenager in the
church social you more than anyone
helped to bring public attention and law
enforcement attention to the case of the
apostle now that the trial date has been
set what's your reaction
thank you brian
well first and foremost my friends and i
and thousands of
xldm members
were ecstatic um me and my friends we
didn't know whether to cry well i cried
we we were shaken we hugged we
celebrated
um finally after almost three years uh
we're gonna have our day in court uh the
defense tried to argue that you and
others uh exaggerated the innocence of
the young women who are alleged to be
the victims of the apostle and that you
were doing this all to make money now
the judge rejected those arguments but
what do you say about the defense
argument
i think it's repulsive
of
what they are saying of these young
women
they were
violated they were
used as as objects
for his sexual pleasure and the evidence
is there
and the truth will come out
and
the fact that
they say that we manipulate it and this
is all for money none of the interviews
that i have ever given have been for a
penny
i have never asked for a penny
i have my husband works he repairs rims
he had his job in politics and we left
all of that to raise awareness on this
issue and the defense is as
they're doing their job and they're
defending a criminal
so that's all i have to say about that
for you to speak out and to come forward
you've paid a heavy price for that uh
with your own family and with your
friends has the church tried to come
after you in other ways
many times many times they followed us
that 24-hour watch in when i was in our
when we were in our house in ensenada
our friends we happen to know as well as
the families of the chain does uh we
have all in in one way or another they
have used their tactics even in the
court they have their bodyguards outside
they have
done a above and beyond to show that
they are exactly what we have mentioned
in the civilrico case they are an
institution of organized crime
the church continues to support the
apostle and they say he should be
released immediately as best you know as
the church conducted any independent
investigation of the allegations against
him
it it breaks my heart brian it it
yesterday we couldn't believe that they
had the members
on a 24-hour prayer and they had they
were in the in the in the province in
guadalajara
they were buying ornaments and they were
up all night and in prayer 24 hours and
organizing this takes
thousands and thousands of dollars
in just waiting because they promised
them brian
that nathan was going to be released
yesterday and that he would be in
and they had the red carpet they had
everything waiting for him to arrive and
for them to honor him and shower him
with gifts it's sad
he will be behind bars until the trial
which is now set to begin in june
what will happen to the church if he's
convicted facing a possible life
sentence
they already have their
next apostle in line it's adorain
joaquin we all know that
and it's just going to be the same
pattern of behavior and that's the
problem
all right social well will you be at the
trial yourself are you going to attend
i will i will be attending um
with
with our friends who have been in this
movement and others uh we will be there
to support
and only there to support
the jane and john does
social martin thank you so much for
being with us tonight
thank you brian
we have repeatedly asked for a
representative of the church to appear
in our program but the answer has always
been no the invitation remains open
up next a taste of freedom for a man who
spent more than 30 years behind bars for
a murder he says he did not commit
now a court may order him back to prison
we have the latest
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network